[Musik]
lass mich raten keiner von euch weiß
warum die Rechner aus der Computer AG
versuchen russische Atomkraftwerke
abzuschalten
okay
ihr habt von sowas keine Ahnung dann
kommt unser heutiges nachsitzthema genau
richtig wir behandeln die glorreiche
Geschichte des Internets hoffentlich
bevor das Schul WLAN wieder
zusammenbricht mal gucken wie tiktok
nein dafür gibt's den regulären
Unterricht also zum wach werden gleich
mal ein Schocker für euch
früher gab es eine Welt ohne Internet
ja aber dann der 29 oktober 1969 Leonard
klein Rock Verband zwei Computer nicht
per Kabel sondern mit WLAN langweilig
falsch WLAN war damals Science Fiction
so wie eine ernstzunehmende
Bildungspolitik heute klein Rock sendete
seine Informationen über apanet eins der
ersten Netzwerke darüber wurde 1971 auch
die allererste E-Mail verschickt sie
landete
okay das Netz wuchs aber man brauchte zu
Hause ein teures Modem oder diesen
Bausatz hier vom Chaos Computerclub da
hat man das hat man an den Telefonhörer
dran geschrieben
fragt eure Großeltern was ein
Telefonhörer war zum Glück wurde sowohl
die Hardware besser als auch die
Software und das verdanken wir
Tim burgersley diese Legende entwickelte
das World Wide Web in dem ihr heute Chat
GPT eure Hausaufgaben machen lasst ihr
sauber Alter Ehrenmann
li erfand die websprache HTML Browser
URL und das Verlinken
ab 1990 können auch Privatpersonen das
World Wide Web nutzen mit einem Browser
1995 macht der Internet Explorer alle
anderen Browser platt weil Bill Gates
seinen Explorer auf jedem Windows
Computer Zwangs installieren lässt Bill
Gates der Typ der uns während Corona
Computerchips eingepflanzt hat ganz
ruhig euch bringen keine Computerchips
um sondern der Klimawandel
die Suchmaschine Google geht im Jahr
1998 online 2001 die Online-Enzyklopädie
Wikipedia Mitte der 2000er Jahre ist das
Internet so beliebt da verdient sich in
der Werbung jeder schmierige semi-promi
eine goldene Nase
boah Internetauktion da gebe ich mein
Gebot für die original Ronaldo
Zahnspange extra in letzter Sekunde und
dann schnapp mir das irgend so ein
Sackgesicht vor der Nase weg da fallen
mir immer die Worte eines kleinen
klugscheißers ein Papa lass es du bist
zu langsam für diese Welt
muss man sich mal vorstellen den Typen
hielten wir damals verlustig
2005 startete Youtube bis heute einer
der erfolgreichsten Webseiten weltweit
gucken da zwei einhalb Milliarden Nutzer
täglich eine Milliarde Stunden Video das
ist unglaublich oder nicht für euch
vermutlich egal bereits 2004 beginnt
eine neue Zeitrechnung für bumerinnen
wie mich Mark Zuckerberg entwickelt mit
Freunden der facebook.com es bricht das
Social Media Zeitalter an und das
verdanken wir auch den mobilen Internet
Dank des ersten iPhones wurde es endlich
möglich auf der Toilette Klopapier zu
bestellen wenn es dringend ist dann mit
Amazon Prime keine Zeit
2011 dachte man kurz das soziale Medien
mega nützlich sein könnten arabischer
Frühling autoritäre Präsidenten in
Tunesien Ägypten Libyen und dem Jemen
werden gestürzt auch dann Facebook und
Twitter leider endet das meist in neuen
Diktaturen oder ja Bürgerkriegen dafür
dass es uns Internet geht verbreiten sie
ziemlich schlechte Laune das Netz hat
auch mega nice Sachen gucken Sie mal
tiktok Politiker die wilden shit machen
oh Gott ihr insta Opfer
was ist denn mit Edward
snowdenblauer 2013 globale Überwachung
durch den Ami Geheimdienst NSA der
Wahlsieg von Donald Trump MC Fake News
great again oder Elon Muskau auf der
Twitter und schreibt Meinungs
Freiheit jeder der das mit der
entwickelt hat was davor dass uns das
irgendwann
dann
eigentlich will ich nur zurück in die
Zeit als wir uns in WhatsApp Gruppen
lustige Katzen Gifs geschickt haben da
habe ich was für euch vorbereitet so
hier die haben eine Party so die hat
ihre Freunde da die hat einen Hut anna
ist praktisch aber du bist so doof heißt
das wir können gehen
danke für alle willst du mit mir
Wasserskifahren hallo du kannst mir auch
alles am Computer
[Musik]
Internet
Verschwörungstheorien Make-up Tutorial
Videos wo die junge Angela Merkel
Geschenkpapier bügelt oder die Wildecker
Herzbuben i want to break free von Queen
im Fernsehgarten sehen oder ihr schaut
euch einfach diese Videos hier an